okay as you might recall a Donald Trump
had big promises about solving the
israeli-palestinian conflict and the big
promise was he's going to solve it which
is a very very big promise to make
particularly from someone like Trump who
understands nothing about the conflict
as as we found out now this obviously
represented a total lack of
understanding by Trump and even the
people around him of the conflict but
his actions were also always
counterproductive in terms of the
israeli-palestinian conflict you'll
remember Donald Trump selected David
Friedman to be the US ambassador to
Israel guys outrageous right wants more
settlements in Israel totally a board of
choice in terms of furthering the peace
process then Trump said that his
son-in-law Jared Kushner was going to be
in charge of the negotiations he has no
experience nor qualifications whatsoever
to be involved in those negotiations and
then more recently late in 2017 Donald
Trump recognized Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel but Jerusalem is a
disputed territory it is part of the
conflict and the United States doing
that goes completely counter to framing
ourselves as possible unbiased arbiters
of peace discussions in the
israeli-palestinian conflict so that's
all the lead-up to yesterday and
yesterday Donald Trump did Trump takes
to Twitter and he threatens to cut off
aid to Palestinians after they
completely understandably say hey listen
the u.s. is recognizing Jerusalem as the
Israeli capital clearly they are not an
unbiased arbiter here we no longer
accept or we will not accept the United
States as a negotiator here it makes
total sense
it was completely predictable after
Donald Trump recognized Jerusalem as the
capital and then Trump takes to Twitter
in response to this statement from the
Palestinians and says it's not only
Pakistan that we pay billions of dollars
to for nothing but also many other
countries and others as an example we
pay the Palestinians hundreds of
millions of dollars a year and get no
appreciation or respect
they don't even want to negotiate a
long-overdue peace treaty with Israel we
have taken Jerusalem the toughest
part of the negotiation off the table
but Israel for that would have had to
pay more but with the Palestinians no
longer willing to talk peace why should
we make any of these massive future
payments to them let's break this down
into its component parts and take it
step by step as I like to it's
completely legitimate to question
foreign aid payments to other countries
and to other people's period of course
that is valid Donald Trump is right that
it has been very difficult to get
Palestinian representatives to the table
to negotiate peace in good faith there's
no doubt about that and by the way the
truth is that the current Israeli
government also doesn't really want to
negotiate peace and good faith Benjamin
Netanyahu benefits from the status quo
that's another story which I've talked
about many times before but for Donald
Trump to publicly and embarrassingly
threatened to pull funding via Twitter
is self-sabotage or as William Shatner
says sabotage for the peace negotiations
that Trump said he wanted to succeed
with that's the sick reality of this
Trump is sabotaging his own agenda right
he ran on solving the conflict he ran on
Jared Kushner and David Freedman are
gonna get it all taken care of and
wrapped up for us like negotiating with
a flooring contractor in one of his
buildings and Trump's own actions are
gonna make that more difficult and
obviously when he fails he'll just blame
the Palestinians right and his followers
by and large will fall for it hook line
and sinker but the clear failure on this
issue that Trump is rapidly heading
towards is going to be his own doing and
of course he's going to blame everyone
else
definitely extra erratic in the new year
don't you think Pat I mean we're only on
day three of 2018 and already three
pseudo significant scandals caused just
by erratic tweets from the guy yeah I
mean this is an opportunity for him to
start a new chapter and the way that
yeah do you turn a page especially after
giving Israel exactly what they want and
are cognizing Jerusalem as the capital
is to give something to the Palestine
Palestinians to bring them to the table
right that he's doing the opposite he's
pushing them further away by tweeting
that on top of it I'll cut aid from you
yeah I mean if any one thing you want to
Zaid or maybe even commit to something
like reducing the settlements there
something say something do you believe
this idea that's being floated that the
reason for these three outrageous tweets
is to take attention away from what
seems to be an about to explode Russia
investigation or do you think that
trumps just not smart enough to even do
something like that but it's hard to
predict where that's all going right I
mean I have to imagine that he has some
sort of insight as to where it's all
heading you think his lawyers are
telling him what's going on I don't know
we'll talk more about what's going on
with with the Russia situation tomorrow
but I really can't understand why it's
unforced error after unforced error and
in a sense that sort of been a theme of
this administration and I know some
people are probably sick of hearing me
say this but a lot of the Russia scandal
wouldn't exist if it weren't for
unforced errors from Donald Trump tweets
that really weren't necessary the firing
of James Comey which again if he knows
that he's guilty of doing really bad
things I guess you fire Comey because
Comey inevitably was going to figure out
what you did but bringing more attention
to the entire Russia thing it is
unforced errors that are the theme of
this administration and no shortage of
them in 2018 I discussed this with us on
our subreddit david pakman.com slash our
IDI di t today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with
Parker they started just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS